all right welcome back to hannity we
continue from beautiful miami
no income tax state florida and we're
here with florida governor ron desantis
senator marco rubio who
really worked hard to get here in spite
of working all
late this afternoon and also joining us
now is the daughter of political
refugees from cuba
florida congresswoman she's been a
friend of the show for a long time and a
friend of my radio show maria salazar
great to see you
thank you very much for and welcome to
little havana the heart of my district
it's the heart of the cuban exile
community and we really wish that the
biden administration would be paying
attention
to us the same way that you are so we
thank you very much for doing this
putting the spotlight on what's
happening in cuba
you're very welcome it's my pleasure and
from the time i met all three of you
you're all passionate about this
issue one question i have when joe biden
now they've been facilitating this law
breaking at our southern border
and basically nobody gets sent back you
just get okay
it's not even catch and release it's
just write down your name
release and we'll ship you off to
another state um
but if you come by c uh
joe is saying um no you'll be sent
back am i to read anything into that
well i think what you read into it is
that uh he is not paying attention to
those people that are screaming on the
streets of havana libertad
you know they're not saying down with
the embargo or we want more vaccines or
we want more food
no they're saying we want freedom and
something that uh that my colleagues
said here is that
many uh demonstrations you see the
american flag
so what a coincidence that you're seeing
the american flag for people that
feel the oppression of socialism well in
this country unfortunately some people
are spitting on it
so it goes to show you that the
socialism regardless of what word you
put in front or behind it
it doesn't work and and what i'm saying
sean
once again we thank you is that the
biden administration needs to pay
attention to us
does everybody agree biden has been
missing in action
you know i i think back there was a time
in this country
when ronald reagan supported the freedom
fighters
in nicaragua to fight their own battle
but they were fighting for the freedom
movement there and
um beyond the internet which is
brilliant we need communication
should that be on the table the miami
mayor even said
very aggressively what do you thought
senator
i mean the first thing is it took biden
24 hours just to issue a statement
and then another 72 hours to say a
second thing and then they did some zoom
call with some people and then it came
back with some third
weekend statement so i don't think you
can right now we can't even get him to
do the internet how are we going to do
anything else
that's the real challenge here with all
of this by the way if you missed
senator rubio's twitter timeline it was
it's now 8
30 not a word from biden now 10 10 not a
word from biden
i mean i really think single-handedly
you embarrassed him into finally making
it
it's just not a priority for them and
you have to understand again there's a
segment of his voting base
that actually thinks the regime is good
that actually brags about the regime
other people that openly say it i mean
the black lives matter foundation said
that our great
and i said that's great my office will
help the black lives matter foundation
immigrate to cuba we stand ready
great point
governor i you're right every
there are people that i have that were
nearly crying that i met on the way
in here correct they can't communicate
now with their loved ones and their
friends and their family
and the internet is crucial i agree with
you you've been right about that
and i think there is great cowardice of
biden is there more we can do what is
what what should the doctrine be if we
talk about a doctrine
well this is western hemisphere i mean
you know one road doctrine we we want to
have
no influence of places like russia and
china
and i can guarantee you if biden is
missing in action more you're going to
see
china and russia and some of those have
even more influence on the island of
cuba
without question so i think you can work
with the organization of american states
i think you can work with
other members of the international
community to stand together
and support people who are being
oppressed this should be a no-brainer
given the history of 62 years of
repression
instead you have biden's administration
having our own country be criticized for
racism they're inviting that that's
their priority
rather than helping folks who uh who
could really make a difference so it's
it's bizarre
it's very bizarre all right
now we turn to the radical organization
known as black lives matter which
recently voiced support for cuba's
murdering communist dictatorship joining
us now with a full report
and there have been others that have
praised cube over the years oh let's see
bernie sanders
michael moore bragging about their great
health care system
one of the dumbest things you've ever
said aoc
and others full report our own david
webb is
outside tonight with us here in miami
david
hey sean and by the way i've been out
here since this began
first when they came out to the streets
on a sunday afternoon
into the night this is not going to end
any time and it shouldn't this cuba's
cry for freedom
is what we're seeing but here in america
we have a marxist
based organization black lives matter
say they care about black lives what
about afro-cubans
they don't because communism doesn't
know color and
marxists like black lives matter have
come out
not tacitly but outwardly in support of
the cuban regime
against the people they're a fraud it's
a grift
but they're a dangerous fraud and grift
and i went up and down kyoto
spoke to so many people including
visitors cuban sons daughters
grandsons granddaughters i also spoke to
people who have survived prison in cuba
and believe me they don't understand but
they do understand communism they don't
understand
how anyone in this country anyone
supported by the democrat socialists of
america
can support communism and we have that
in congress we have that in the united
states senate
i spoke to this one young woman just
watch this
a lot of people in this country not only
are concerned about this but on the
other side there are people
who follow the black lives matter
movement now they say they're for black
lives
they say they support the people but yet
they just came out in support of the
communist government in cuba
what do you say to black lives matter i
believe that
if you fight for injustice against a
group of people
what the cubans are going through is
injustice so how can you
allow or support this injustice against
a group of people that are oppressed
if the if they are fighting against
oppressed oppression
of the colored people guess what there's
colored people in cuba too what about
their lives
do their lives not matter
she said it well sean the world should
be listening
alicia garza op altometti patrice calors
are multi-millionaire communists
supporting the cuban regime back to you
sean
from outside cafe versailles
all right david thank you joining us now
is a cuban-born
democracy activist founder of cuba
decide
uh rosa maria paya is with us as we also
continue with senator marco rubio
governor ron desantis is with us great
to see you
you know i i will tell you with all the
people that i talk to out there
i'm i find it inspiring i know you know
we take things for granted right
i we probably should all wake up every
day and before our feet hit the ground
think and you know the rest of the world
doesn't live free
when you when i read the statistics
about the poverty
widespread it is so preventable
and yet this oppression goes on and
murder and death and
and no freedom exactly and not just
that in addition to that there is a huge
propaganda machinery portraying
a very oppressive dictatorial
totalitarian dictatorship of the
of the one that we have in cuba as a
beacon of
happiness liberty and even healthcare
system when the people in cuba cannot
even find
aspirants in the yeah and you know
i really believe and i discussed this
earlier that
can you imagine cuba five years from now
if this was a successful freedom liberty
movement
could you imagine the investment first
of all what beautiful geography
what incredible resorts would be built
what did what
money and investment would go into the
the coastal towns
the jobs created the wealth created you
know people
finally now prospering they would have
their first chance the cuban people also
imagined that
we also imagined so and that's why we
are asking for freedom at the end of the
dictatorship that's the only thing that
we need
to make to produce medicine and food and
buildings and to be prosperous and
a and a beautiful country that actually
could be
an example in the world let me ask a
quick question of our crowd
should show a hands or clap maybe clap
it would be easier
how many people here have loved ones
friends
neighbors relatives that you send money
to because
you know how badly they are suffering a
lot of people help people out
in cuba that are in cuba now that you
would that you're helping
you're all raising your hand but they
can't see them at all on tv
but uh
because you're helping a lot of people
that are pretty desperate all right
we're gonna take a break now this is
gonna be fun we're gonna go outside
a lot of demonstrators they've been
outside from day one as this
liberty movement has started speaking
out against the evils of communism in
cuba
they'll have their opportunity to talk
to governor desantis and senator rubio
as we continue live in miami it's
hannity on the fox news channel hey sean
hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else